hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the mcdonald
gambit in
the kings game but king's game it starts
out e4 e5
pawn to f4 this is my favorite chess
opening of all time
if you watch my videos for a while you
definitely know this about me and after
the pawn takes
knight to f3 pretty common variation
from here
pawn g5 bishop here to c4
pawn to g4 attacking the knight here
and now this is where the mcdonald
gambit comes into play and if you're
like me if you have a favorite chess
opening you usually have different lines
that you like to play against your
opponents
my main line that i go to is the muzio
gambit and that's castling here on
the king side pawn takes queen takes
here on f3
and white has a very strong attack but i
also really like to play the mcdonald
gambit and that says
let's not castle on the king's head
right away instead let's just get more
material involved
into the game so if you haven't played
knight to c3
i definitely recommend it in this video
we're going to be looking at the
accepted line that is pawn taking here
on f3
there are other variations that black
may decide to play does not have to take
here on f3 and
actually i think there's some very good
lines that black has
without just taking this knight here on
f3
not going to be going over that in this
video but when this video
hopefully this video at some point
reaches 25 000 views
that's going to be my signal to say go
ahead and make
the decline line so definitely show your
support for the video
share this with your friends so as it
hits 25 000 i'll go and make that
decline line
but in this one we are going to be
looking at pawn takes here on f3
same as you would expect in the muzio
game but the queen's going to come
to f3 intake here they're going to be
looking at different lines the first one
is d6 pretty common theme ever since the
days back and bobby fischer
said a king's game it all you have to do
is play d6 from black and you can pretty
much
win uh so that's one variation we're
going to be looking at the second one is
going to be
knight to f6 a pretty standard
opening from black here we're going to
look at d5 just trying to blow up the
entire center of the board and then
something that used to be looked at
is you know queen here on f3 attacking
the pawn
bishop to h6 trying to hold on to that
pawn here on
f4 the first version we are going to
look at is
d6 white's just going to castle on the
king side
you can start to see the queen and the
rook lining up here on
this f file this bishop here on c4
also eyeing down this f7 square so a lot
of pressure
on black eventually none of the material
here on this eighth rank have
moved uh for black now black was able to
capture that knight
was able to capture that pawn here on f4
although
we've captured one of those pawns uh
back
but you can see that uh black may decide
hey we're up a material here let's go
ahead and start to exchange off so this
bishop here on c4
is a huge threat eyeing down this f7
square they could play
maybe bishop to e6 okay well
now there's just going to be an exchange
and after this right here
then queen to h5 check that pawn here
on f7 is no longer being able to defend
this king
the king has to move no other square and
so while
white doesn't have the pawn here on f2
you can still see that the white king is
pretty safe and this
black king on d7 is going to be chase
for the rest of the game here
d4 you can see this does open up to
attack this pawn here on f4 from
uh the bishop here it doesn't matter if
the king comes to
d7 or e7 i think both of these white's
just gonna be looking to play
pawn to d4 now maybe they don't want to
trade off it and they see the exchange
and they say okay that's not gonna work
out really well for me maybe
knight two f6 well in this case yeah
we're just
going to be playing pawn to d4
this bishop here is attacking the pawn
uh
that they can't really hold on to this
pawn at all you know bishop to h6 does
absolutely nothing because the bishop
queen
and rook from whites are eyeing down so
it's just too much material here
because now just bishop takes here on f4
and black just kind of sits there and
realizes okay i just wasted a move
i can't actually defend that material so
maybe they play something else maybe
bishop two
e7 okay well now the queen just takes
here
on f4 and you can start to see white
definitely controls the center of the
board
black isn't going to be castling on the
queens at any time soon the
king side safety is kind of blown up
after the pawn from the g-file uh
is gone uh so that's definitely gonna be
tough you could also see
maybe rook to uh g8 just trying to
control this semi-open
g-file but now the bishop takes here on
f4 as we said before
white has two central pawns the bishops
both
are controlling the center of this board
just seems very difficult for black to
stop all the threats that white has
now maybe black doesn't play bishop 2 f6
maybe instead
bishop to g7 just trying to control the
center of the board here
white's just going to take here on f4
but this does open up for bishop to d4
check
doesn't really matter too much king 2h1
is just a nice little
safety uh here and then maybe
maybe knight to f6 knight to
d5 attacking the knight here what's nice
here is
that there's a real threat here yes the
bishop
on c4 was attacking the pawn but also
there's this barrel right here and if
the knight takes that's going to be
checkmate right here can't take that so
what other options do they have
maybe in this case they play bishop to
e6 but now just knight takes here on f6
maybe the bishop takes you see the
exchange on the board
at the end of the day i think this is
going to be completely fine for white
going into the end game up a pawn
in material also has the bishop which is
going to be able to
really control a lot of the game where
this knight is not
going into the end game nearly as strong
as that bishop
if we come back a few moves bishop to e6
just looked at that variation maybe
knight to d7
i do think that this makes some sense
just because this
knight is defending the knight here on
f6 so
trying to solidify something here from
all the critical squares that white is
controlling
white can just slowly start to chip away
here pawn to c3 forcing the bishop to
come back
there's no real great squares bishop to
e5 does attack the
queen here but then just queen to f3
just bring it back a little bit still
controlling the semi
open f file and you can start to see
that black doesn't have a lot of great
squares the queen here on d8s completely
blocked in can't come
to e7 that's still defended by this
knight here
on d5 you can see light square bishop's
now completely blocked off
black king here on e8 yeah i mean i
guess if you want to castle on the king
side but then that opens up
a lot more threats here and you can see
the next move from whites you play pawn
to d4
attacking this bishop opening up for the
dark square bishop to get involved into
the game bring your rook over and start
to attack on the king side of the board
i like this attack from white quite a
bit
so that was if they play pawn to d6 what
i do think is the most common line that
you will see but they could try some
other random stuff
knight to f6 here i don't think it's the
best option you can just go ahead and
capture here on f4
and then they're probably going to be
looking to just play something in the
center of the board with pawn to d6 and
we've already looked at how to approach
that but if maybe something else
knight to c6 here well then you're just
gonna castle on
the king's side eyeing down the same
threats we had before
on this fi here with your queen rook and
your bishop here on
c4 and then maybe bishop to g7 from them
but then you just push forward e5
there's just so many threats it's very
difficult for them to deal with that
uh maybe bishop here to c5 check but
then after the king moves here
there's just no real good way for them
to continue uh
they're going to lose material here
maybe rook 2
f8 we just take the knight here on
f6 just don't think they have many good
options there so
instead i think one that's more common
you will see instead of
pawn to d6 you may also see pawn two d5
black is up material they got that
knight there on f3
so they may say let's just go ahead and
blow up the center of the board
as long as i'm not cramped i should have
a good game knight takes here on
d5 getting that material but they do
have open lines
for their pieces they just haven't moved
anything on this eighth rank
which is part of the reason people like
playing many of these lines in
the king's gambit it's definitely why i
like to just has so many aggressive
pieces here
they could try to now attack the knight
just pawn to c6
we're just going to take the material on
f4 pretty easy decision for us
and even if they continue to attack us
maybe bishop to e6 getting
more material involved into the game
from them since they don't have anything
else
but they they really don't understand
just
how much we have as far as threats
knight to g6 is a real threat because
this threatens queen to f7
checkmate but it also attacks the
rookier on h8 they definitely have to
deal with the checkmate first so maybe
maybe queen two f6 but then we could
just take
with our knights here on hh they're
probably gonna take our queen
and we take their queen back uh you know
even if they take
our knights right here and they just say
we'll go down two ponds of material
we just take with our queen right here
after the king moves
we can just exchange right here uh going
into the end game
we should be very good both sides have a
bishop pair
and then we have a rook and a knight
versus two rooks
we have more pawns in our opponent
definitely should be an easy
game for us if we come back a few moves
and let's say they don't play that pawn
to
c6 maybe instead of attacking
the knights they look at and say let's
just go ahead and get our knight
involved into the game here
and we just go ahead and take with our
queen
on f4 keep the knight here great little
outpost if it's not being attacked we
don't have to move it it was just pretty
easy for us if it was attacked go ahead
and come back here to f4
but that's definitely an option if they
don't play
pawn to the center of the board as i
mentioned at the beginning of the video
bishop here to h6
trying to defend this pawn is one option
but really white can just overwhelm that
square
pawn to d4 white's definitely
controlling the center of the board
opens up for the dark square bishop to
attack that
uh no real good way for them to
keep that pressure on knight to c6 here
white castle's on the king side
queen rook and bishop all eyeing down
here and the bishop here on h6
is really trying to defend this when
black really needs to start opening up
lines to
counter attack in the center of the
board and build up a stronger
defense this does not do that at all so
this is just an introduction to the
mcdonald gambit in
the king's gambit my favorite opening so
hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video if you haven't tried
this out maybe you've only been playing
the museo gambits
i definitely recommend trying this
knight to c3 at the beginning let me
know what you guys think
again if we do get to 25 000 i will be
making the
decline lines just so you can see what
happens hey if they didn't take my
knight on
f3 what do i do thank you so much for
watching this video thank you for the
support
let me know if there's any other
extended lines in your favorite chess
opening you would like me to make
and i just may make that in a future
video so thanks again
i'll see you guys in the next video
you